[Applaudissements]
avant comme les visionnements des crous
bon sang pourquoi tu veux c'est que ces
joyaux nerfs bah oui j'y crois à la la
fois que ce soit fatou l'asie croît on
sait rachid arhab pas tout c'était toi
tout si c'était toi rappelle nantes et
puis je rappelle rappelle vite
[Musique]
moi j'ai mon sens ça tout ça à tous
niveaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
photo avant que tu es venu avant que tu
nous disent pourquoi tu appelé pas tout
noir attend photo avant que tu me dises
pourquoi tu as appelé un téléphone
autour du cou mais je sais
le dise pourquoi tu as appelé puisque tu
fais suite certainement la déclaration
d'amour de gilles est ce que folie l'ue
appelle appel pourra tôt en faire fatou
pouviez calmes et ils vous avez suivi
des turbulences pnc aux portes contrôle
des visas vis fatou gilles je sais pas
si tu as la télévision gilles est ému
comme les stucs rue dans merde avec sa
photo fatou je sais que depuis ce baiser
langoureux entre l'isabelle et gilles
votre couple a vacillé et aujourd'hui
gilles regrette
gilles n'a qu'une envie sinon c'est
repartir comme avant
main dans la main avec fatou marché dans
les rues de joinville ou d'ailleurs
toujours eu le mobile les mains en crabe
bon écoute on va éviter le marché les
marins crabe lui ont marché ensemble
donc tu laissais de ne plus marcher seul
comme jean jacques goldman
non je me prépare je vais marquer avec
gilles parce que le comble de bonheur
on va de notre plus forte ça et là c'est
de dire que l'homme de ma vie
on va avancer on avancer tranquillement
marquer tranquillement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
être là je voudrais remercier de
m'accompagner de me souvenir de toi même
et tu peux dire que le meilleur
ok mon amour avec le million pour toi je
vais être le meilleur homme pour toi
toute la vie je t'aime chérie je t'aime
je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime et mon
rêve c'est qu'on se marie série c'est
qu'on se marre et membres merci monde
ah oui et je vous remercie et fatou un
vrai atout ma chérie tu sais que je
t'aime fort aussi et tu sais quand tu
sais comme géo j'avoue je sais comme
j'aime gilles c qui est vraiment
quelqu'un qui aime énormément tu le sais
mon fils où il se voir aussi à mu est
aussi heureux ça me fait énormément
plaisir
après deux heures de râteaux ans par un
couple un atout donc demain vous allez
pas de ses cymbales en temps ensemble à
michel aulas sait vous regardez comme
quelque chose mais rappelez merci ma
famille j'adore j'adore finale aller ma
chérie
gilles tu es heureux chez hyper ému
franchement je m'y attendais pas du tout
je connais pas tous c'est que je m'y
attendais pas du tout je suis hyper ému
et pour qu'elle fasse ça vous la
connaissez beaucoup de gens la
connaissent ainsi kelly la connaît bien
pour qu'elle fasse ça c'est vraiment
pour elle un magnifique geste et les
normes je reçois comme tel
merci vraiment fait la pub j'ai été le
voir et m'a dit elle appellera pas mais
bon il a été placé et merci à vous
d'avoir été là merci sans prix nationaux
gilou et je t'aime fort je vais
l'appeler quoi moi aussi